-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
We're hanging out with
Kelly Ripa right here!
The book is out right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
In honor of your book,
"Live Wire:
Long-Winded Short Stories,"
I thought we could put our
talking skills to the test
in a new game called
"The Long-Winded Challenge."
-♪ "Long-winded Challenge" ♪
-Now --
-This game is sure to be a hit.
-Yeah, I know it is.
Yeah, watch.
Here's how it works.
You'll like this.
Each of us take turns picking
a card with a topic on it.
Whatever topic you get,
you have to talk about it
for as long as you can
without taking any breaks.
If you pause or say "um,"
you will be buzzed.
-I say "um" constantly.
-Not in this game.
-Okay.
-Whoever can talk
the longest wins.
Are you ready for this?
-Ready.
-Alright. I'm going to go first.
-Okay, you go first.
-Let me see. My subject is...
Okay. Can we get a timer?
I love submarines.
They're almost like boats,
but they're underwater.
And there was that
one movie with
Alec Baldwin and Sean Connery.
And they were
fighting the Russians,
and it was crazy.
I loved it so much, but I kind
of wish it was in a boat,
because that would be more like
a fun summer movie,
where they're on
a boat together,
Sean Connery and Alec Baldwin.
I would love to see that, uh,
but I didn't see that.
Oh, I said "uh."
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cymbal crash, sad tuba plays ]
-So hard.
-I could have thought about
a submarine sandwich.
-So, that's what I thought.
I was like,
"Submarine is a sandwich."
-I know.
I should have done sandwich.
I could have talked so much
about submarine sandwiches.
I know, I went with that thing.
-I'm going to say "um"
in three seconds
because it only takes that long.
-Let's see what your word is.
What if it's "um"?
-My word is New Jersey.
-Alright.
-I love New Jersey
because it is the Garden State.
A lot of people
don't realize that New Jersey
was founded by
our forefathers...
-Are you British?
-...many years ago.
If I do not --
[ Buzzer ]
-No, don't give her
the buzz on that.
Hey, that's not fair.
Don't give her the buzz on that.
I interrupted her.
That's not fair.
She was telling a beautiful
British story about New Jersey.
Keep the timer going.
-Nobody said that I was
not to use a British accent
at any point in this story.
There are two parts of
New Jersey --
North Jersey and I like to call
the superior South Jersey.
-Oh, my God.
-Near Philadelphia,
we are Philadelphia-adjacent,
and, therefore,
we own Rocky Balboa.
-What are you talking about?
-New Jersey is famous for its
truck stops, rest stops,
Wawas, 7-Elevens,
and, of course --
[ Buzzer ]
-Alright. Oh, my God.
That's not bad.
Rocky Balboa?
What are you talking about?
-I don't know.
I had to talk about New Jersey,
which eventually
leads to Philadelphia.
-You crushed me on that one.
Okay, it is time for
the final round.
For this, we're going to talk
about the same topic,
but alternate every 5 seconds.
-Every 5 seconds.
-So when we hear this ding...
[ Ding ]
...we'll alternate.
The other person has to continue
where the other person
left off and keep going until --
Whoever messes up loses.
-Okay, yeah.
-Here we go, bud.
-Ready.
-We're going to have to talk
about -- ooh! -- apples.
-Apples.
-Okay. I can do this.
Remember, switching off
every 5 seconds.
So, I'll start us off.
[ Laughs ]
I love apples so much.
Green ones, red ones,
yellow ones.
[ Ding ]
-Granny Smith apples
are the greatest apples
in all of the orchard.
-Of course, the apple originated
by Johnny Appleseed.
[ Ding ]
-Did you know that
you can shoot an apple off of
someone's head
with nothing more --
-Do I know
or have I experienced it?
Yes, of course, I have gotten
an apple shot off my head.
[ Ding ]
-You can use grenade to blow up
a whole orchard of apples.
[ Ding ]
-Now you're speaking
about applesauce.
And that's how it was invented.
-I like apple pie,
not just sauce.
-I'm going to give you
the win on this.
Come on. Kelly Ripa.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
The British accent -- Why did
the British accent come out?
-It's the only way --
-That's the only we enjoy it.
I love you. Kelly Ripa.
Her book, "Live Wire:
Long-Winded Short Stories,"
is available now
wherever books are sold.
We'll be right back
with Kid Cudi.
Come on back.